et tu es pas ta famille tu fais pas des
enfants non plus mais on est en juillet
pas aux histoires de drogue ce n'est pas
un assassin c'est un voyou alors on le
jour 2 de son assassinat
comment vous l'apprenez mais enfin tu as
in fine à ryadh même pas le rap sur la
photo il ya 27 ans de procédure pour
obtenir un non-lieu à la fin donc alors
on va voir dans le documentaire un
policier voilà qui étaient sur les lieux
qui dit on pouvait pas on est obligé de
tirer les gars c'était mirin s'était pas
n'importe qui on a été obligés de tirer
qu'est ce que vous dites à ça alors moi
je dis camec enfermé dans une bmw
attachée à sa ceinture les deux mains
sur le volant
face à quatre tireurs d'élite qui sont à
3 mètres de lui avec des fusils d'assaut
de l'armée et avec une trentaine de
flics tout autour si mon père est encore
dangereux faut m'expliquer là là comment
vous l'avez appris j'ai appris moi
j'allais j'étais donc à l'abri dans mon
petit village de savoir et j'ai pour la
toussaint je vais sur la tombe de mon
grand père je suis sur la route avec ma
grand-mère heureusement ma grand mère
hannaë n'avait pas d'autoradio
donc on arrive on arrive on arrive à
clichy à l'appartement familial et dans
la rue des centaines des centaines de
personnes et qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe voilà tout le
monde me saute dans les bras tempéré
mort tempéré mandrin savez quel âge
j'avais va dire quinze ans parce que
j'avais 14 ans et elle va te 21 quelques
jours quoi vous avez s'est vite et bien
sûr vous avez pris la nouvelle
robert des textiles et j'ai appris la
nouvelle je monte tout de suite à
l'appartement trop laid mais la
télévision pour fonds veut dire vrai je
rêve où j'aurais voulu
voilà la police n'ont pas la police
j'entends beaucoup parler en ce moment
des violences policières etc c'est
encore un autre sujet donc j'en veux à
broussard et sa petite bande de la salle
commissaire broussard l'enquète pendant
des années des années leurs voeux à ce
mec là et à sa petite bande qui ont reçu
l'ordre de tuer mon père y penser qu'il
aura donné ordre de tuer votre père je
voulais pas mais vous les choix qui
retourne en prison
non mais c'est
quand on est en prison il va refaire
encore du spectacle au dernier procès
qu'il a fait tout le monde applaudissait
non non il voulait plus d'un mec comme
lui parce que le danger pouvait de mon
père c'est ça qui l'a conduit quelque
part sa fin quand on devient considère
populaire ah c'est pas bon ça ben ouais
c'est ça c'est parce qu'il était très
aimée mais les mêmes des sondages sur
lui pour sa part sur sa popularité oui
delphine justement lui l'homme de
l'année par part est malsaine marque
parismatch il était 6e année oui élu
homme de l'année on découvre ouais c'est
ce à quoi oui c'était votre papa donc
vous l'aimiez mais est-ce qu'un jour
vous lui en avait voulu des choix qu'il
a fait dans sa vie parce qu'au final il
faut pas en vouloir à la police ou quoi
que ce soit c'est ses propres choix
répond si je dois en vouloir à mon père
que c'est face à szczesny de cette
manière là je serai pire des [ __ ] de
fisc mes choix il est actuellement payé
fort au prix au prix fort il faut pas en
vouloir à mon père et ses passes
possibles et est populaire parce que
surtout il avait un engagement en
politique
oui oui il est qu à chasser et
d'ailleurs les gens ne mesurent pas être
dans la prison c'était une prison dans
la prison dans une prison moi ce qui m'a
toujours frappé avec vous ce que en fait
il était psychologiquement ils n'avaient
pas craqué parce que dans la chasse à
broyer les gens c'est sûr ça qui
s'évadait quatre quartiers sécurité
c'est quand même le premier motif de son
évasion parce qu'il est dit si je reste
comme ça encore cinq ans mais je serai
brisé je serais cassé et voilà et en
plus une ovation comme sale elle en a
fait une plus fort au canada pour noter
les clients de dacca dans la cadre de la
4 voies qu'elle a lus et ses unités
spéciales de correction vous assurez que
celle des lillois sur les vélos sion
renault est ce que vous vous avez songé
un moment à faire la même carrière que
votre père quand on perd son papa du
jeune pilote d'hélicoptère de france
militaire on m'a dit à l'époque est
inquiet du pilote pour faire rêver les
tempèrent problème c'est que mon père
était déjà mort depuis quelques années
donc je suis devenu magicien
quelque part c'est pas loin de mon père
tout le long de sa cavale il s'appelle
bruno après je veux dire pendant lâche
qu'on de 16 à 18 ans oui j'ai été
presque tous les soirs garde à vue
oui là je vous parle et quand vous étiez
en garde a nommé un moment je commence à
avoir ma photo dans tous les
commissariats et je commence à me dire
mais c'est pas bon ça bah ouais vous
disais c'est pas bon non ce n'est pas
pas du tout cherché non et déjà être
pressée pas de fierté ses collègues et
se dit je suis fier d'avoir été violée
je suis fier d'avoir été en prison non
n'y a pas de fierté
vous avez été la fiancée tarder par des
gens voilà qui me dit oui
ton père tous les bords dans tous les
sens
ouais bon et vous avez toujours dit si
l'idée vous avez du don oui toujours
oui nous n'avons pas tiré des problèmes
non non non